Britney grainer puede ser la llave de
Rusia para recuperar a Víctor vaugh la
figura del apodo mercader de la muerte
objetivo de Moscú desde su detención en
2008 está sobre la mesa de negociaciones
en un intercambio que incluiría a la
basquetbolista estrella y Alex Marín
Paul William el viceministro de
exteriores ruso sergey dio pocos
detalles pero se mostró optimista
quiero esperar que la perspectiva no
solo permanezca sino que se fortalezca y
que llegue el momento en que logremos un
acuerdo concreto estamos trabajando
profesionalmente a través de un canal
especial diseñado para esto Víctor boult
está entre los que se están discutiendo
y ciertamente Contamos con un resultado
positivo
por su parte Estados Unidos recalcó las
fallas constantes de Rusia en las
conversaciones este viernes el portavoz
adjunto del departamento de estado vean
papel afirmó que el kremlin no negoció
seriamente por los canales establecidos
entretanto greiner fue derivada mordovia
conocida desde la época soviética por
sus colonias penales
las cárceles de mujeres de mordovia como
el centro Correccional dos donde Britney
ha sido enviada son muy conocidas entre
los defensores de los Derechos Humanos
por sus horribles condiciones de trabajo
las mujeres allí son castigadas castigan
a la unidad que tiene la culpa cuando no
han trabajado lo suficiente no reciben
agua caliente por días
Rusia y Estados Unidos tienen
antecedentes en intercambios de
prisioneros pero Washington siempre fue
reticente a liberar about sin embargo la
estadía de griner en mordovia puede
cambiar el panora